[Musique]
les progrès de la science nucléaire ne
sont-ils pas à la fois une étape vers
l'âge d'or et un risque d'apocalypse ce
qu'il est raisonnable d'espérer nous
sommes allés le demander à celui que
l'on appelle le père de la bomba le
docteur Oppenheimer qui vit maintenant à
l'écart à l'université de Princeton et
qui n'est pas un homme heureux
en trouvant le moyen de désintégrer la
matière l'homme a découvert un secret
qui le dépasse et qu'il est en train de
creuser son propre tombeau qu'en
pensez-vous vous
c'est bien possible
je ne suis pas optimiste
mais je maintiens une espoir
sous quelle forme cet espoir
qu'on trouvera le chemin
et quand on dans
la gravité
des dangers
leur totalité
on retrouvera le centre commun
est très rare
une
sorte de communauté humaine
en somme vous pensez que l'homme ayant
trouvé maintenant quelque chose
de tellement grave que c'est à l'échelle
planétaire que le danger est couru il
faut que ce soit aussi à l'échelle
planétaire que les hommes se réunissent
je te crois bien
[Musique]